à parlons peu parlons bien parlons d air
taag les attaques c'est quoi leur taxe
et ça ça est-ce que le post fait les
airs taxes et ça c'est cette espèce de
petit tracker qu'on va pouvoir attacher
à ces affaires qu'on va pouvoir emmener
partout avec soi facilement pour pouvoir
savoir où sont ses affaires et avoir
l'esprit tranquille et se dire je sais
pas ce que j'ai fait de mes affaires
mais c'est pas grave parce que quoi
qu'il se passe
ils ne seront pas perdus alors moi ce
airtag gelé attaché à mes clés grâce un
petit accessoire vendu par apple et je
vous la tâche est ici à mes clés gelé ou
verges l'église c'est dedans comme ça
c'est très pratique en existe de toutes
sortes de ses accessoires d'ailleurs
vous aimez les liens en bas dans la
description leicester n'est pas ce que
c'est assez intéressant
il ya du bleu il ya du rouge ya des
grands il y a des petits de toutes
sortes pour tout le monde et ça c'est
sympa alors les retailler sont vendus
soit par un à l'unité comme ça soit par
lot de quatre mois je m'en suis mis
plusieurs j'en ai mis un bien évidemment
sur mac les clés principales et j'en ai
bien dans mon sac gopro jean emilien
dans mon sac avec tout mon matériel de
vidéo et j'en ai bien dans mon
portefeuille histoire d'avoir une vision
un peu complète et il me reste encore un
avenir à signer et je le ferai un peu
plus tard et moi je voulais vous parler
d'astuces parce qu'il ya plein de choses
qu'on ne sait pas nécessairement sur l'
usage de ces attaques sur ce qu'on va
pouvoir venir en faire donc ce qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui c'est de savoir
comment est-ce qu'on va venir utiliser
certains gabonais sur comment est-ce
qu'on va réussir à les optimiser pour
bien les utiliser et en fait qu'à plein
de petites choses dont on ne se doutait
pas au début sur le fait qu'on puisse
être traqués parce que oui même si apple
vous dis que là dessus vous ne serez pas
trackers c'est vrai que vous n'avez pas
est traqué par des personnes étrangères
mais vous pouvez être traqués d'une
certaine manière je vais vous expliquer
tout ça je vais vous dire comment éviter
ça quelles sont les options à venir
activé sur son smartphone quand on n'y
pense pas pour justement pour revenir
les utiliser correctement
je vais également vous donner plein de
petites astuces à droite à gauche pour
bien utiliser son application localisés
pour bien utiliser ces petits appareils
bien les configurer changer les pieds
les compagnies donc ça s'est super bien
[Musique]
la première astuce elle coule de source
elle paraît assez logique mais malgré
tout il faut quand même y penser c'est
de l'associer aux bons objets jeu peut
la signer à plein d'objets appareil
photo bagages ok pourquoi pas casque
audio
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que
c'est pas avec les erp et max que je lui
met dedans vu qu'il ya pas de rien pour
le mettre en tout cas si ce n'est une
fois de plus mais bon crochet c'est un
mot cases comme paraître un peu bizarre
que l'époque où carrément porte pluie
j'ai du mal à comprendre portefeuille
des glissades dans sa marche sac à dos
si c'est par là il sac à main ça marche
vélo vélo c'est à dire qu'il vous faut
que si tu t'accroches b est bon pourquoi
pas et après c'est ce qui est plus
intéressant ses côtés personnalisé vous
le mettez dans ce que vous voulez moi
ici je leur portefeuille parce que ça a
un sens
et effectivement je le mets dans votre
portefeuille je glisse je sais où est
mon portefeuille si je les parts du jeu
c'est retrouver facilement de ma carte
bleue sans ces pratiques donc il faut
vraiment me dire avoir cette logique en
vidéo
qu'est ce que je vais devenir enfer où
est ce que je vais venir le m pensez à
ses réels besoins au delà du côté un peu
accessoire rigolo parce que ça coûte
quand même relativement cher donc si
vous vous dites
eh bien je vais en mettre un peu partout
à droite à gauche c'est vous avez cassé
la tirelire il faut avoir une logique en
se disant qu'est-ce que je perds qu'est
ce que je risque de perdre les clés plus
plus plus plus mais au delà des clés
qu'est ce que je risque de perdre un sac
pourquoi pas un sac à main au
portefeuille pour m'apprendre à un sac
deux sacs trois sacs
mais au delà trader dites moi vous
qu'est ce que vous en feriez ou est ce
que vous pourriez les assigner marqué le
mois en commentaire parce que ça ça
m'intéresse
la deuxième astuce c'est un point sur
lequel j'ai galéré et je me fini mais
comment ça se fait que j'y arrive pas qu
est ce qui se passe alors je vous
explique un peu l'histoire c'est très
simple lorsque vous leur chercher il va
venir le localiser dans un périmètre qui
est assez là il va vous donner l'adresse
à quelque chose près mais là où il ya un
vrai usages c'est grâce à la technologie
ultra wide band qui vous permet de le
retrouver dans un périmètre qui est
extrêmement mais extrêmement précis
alors je vous montre l'histoire sac à
dos vidéo là il est là donc là
clairement il vous le dis qu'il est
juste ici je vais les cartes et un tout
petit peu et il me dit qu'il est à
proximité est en fait pour qu'ils
puissent vraiment le détecter à
proximité et vous donner les quelques
mails voyez qu'il le sait pas je leur
approche
il me dit qu'il est juste là et là pour
réussir à faire ça en fait c'est il
utilise la technologie ultra wide band
qu'on retrouve à partir des iphone aux
iphone 11 et versions ultérieures
donc si vous n'avez pas cette ultra wide
band débat ça ne marchera pas et il faut
venir activé il faut bien arrêter parce
que si vous venez pas l'activer et bien
ri à un moment ça ne fonctionnera pas
alors ce qu'il faut faire il faut venir
dans vos paramètres
il faut aller dans confidentialité il
faudrait dans service
localisation et dans services de
localisation vous cherchez votre
application qui s'appelle localiser et
ici il faut que vous veniez l'activer et
que vous mettiez lorsque la peau est
active
ça vous permettra donc de pouvoir
utiliser du travail bon parce que si
vous ne le faites pas si vous mettez
jamais j'étais sûr jamais moi dès le
départ eh bien lorsque vous allez sur
localisés ils vous emmènent sur une
carte alors bien évidemment je la foudre
parce que c'est chez moi donc il vous
emmène sur une carte mais sur une carte
vous voyez à peu près où il est mais
c'est pas extrêmement précis ça vous
permettra pas de localiser chez vous
donc il faut vraiment venir faire ça
vous allez donc dans vos paramètres et
vous mettez lorsque la tête active et là
vous allez pouvoir venir le localiser de
façon très précise et là il fait appel à
l' ultra wide band et voulons trouve ça
assez bien ces pratiques donc ça il faut
vraiment y penser alors il ya un autre
truc est sympa justement lorsque vous
utilisez cette recherche à proximité
grâce à l' ultra wide band et bien des
fois on va galérer un petit peu invasive
m'attendais par où il faut que j'aille
comment ça se passe si un étage est ce
que ça marche il ya une façon très
maline devenir l'utiliser je vous montre
en fait c'est comme sur une boussole
sais pas si vous avez l'habitude d'une
boussole mais c'est un peu le même
principe il vous met il faut que vous
alliez sur votre droite et c'est un peu
ce système comme une boussole regardez
là pour vraiment marche dans la bonne
direction
vous faites marcher votre petit point là
avec votre petit point aux dons vous
tournez votre téléphone j'allume bien
les points voilà donc là je le tourne
pour qu'il corresponde alors il me dit
que c'est par là en fait il est là il me
dit qu'il faut que j'aille là je vais la
jouer là je vais la caisse qui me dit à
proximité voilà ce sont vraiment les
vibrations donc là il vibre pour me dire
chaque côté et là il est ici en plein
jeu décalé effectivement il ici mais
voyez il ya vraiment cet aspect comme un
côté un peu boussole pour venir le
retrouver et utiliser la flèche
voilà quand on est bon qu'on ait aligné
comme ça on peut y aller mais si on se
décale sur le côté on n'est plus bon et
ne sont plus les vibrations donc c'est
un truc tout bête mais il faut avoir
cette logique de boussole pour venir
aligner les choses correctement et ça
marche pour moi ça jamais à chaud ça
c'est pratique donc sa fonction ok alors
maintenant il ya un autre point qui est
super intéressant c'est lorsque se
retrouve dans une pièce où vous n'y
voyez pas grand chose ça va vous
proposer de venir allumé la torche vous
faites localiser et là ce qui va
apparaître
c'est un petit bouton pour venir annulés
et un petit bouton pour faire sonner je
viens obstrue ici au niveau de mes
caméras il voit qu'effectivement il ya
plus lumière ils vous marquent
il faut de la lumière est là haut up là
on appuie il allume la torche
vous allez pouvoir me retrouver et se
serait facilement donc même si vous
manquez lumière et bien soyez quand même
rassuré il vous fera apparaître cette
petite icône torche qui n'apparaît pas
classiquement
mais lorsque vous montrez lunaire et
bien vous pour en avoir donc ça c'est
aussi très bien autre astuce qui parlera
un peu tout bête mais qui est quand même
très très pratique lorsque vous êtes sur
votre smartphone vous voulez savoir où
sont vos clés où sont mes clés syrie je
cherche c'est très bien le aurélia
proximité et vous fait sonner vos clés
donc ça c'est extrêmement pratique donc
on peut également utiliser siri pour
venir retrouver ces objets très
facilement commande vocale où que vous
soyez alors il ya un autre point qui est
extrêmement intéressant et dont je
voulais vous parler c'est à dire le fait
de pouvoir traquer également vos objets
sur ipad
alors je vous montre j'ai un ipad pro
qui l'a mise à jour 14 points 5
c'est important de venir faire votre
mise à jour sur vos ipad pour vous
puissiez en profiter toujours pareil
version 14.5 sinon ça ne marchera pas il
n'y aura pas de prise en charge et là
vous allez pouvoir retrouver vos objets
très facilement directement dans votre
ipad
donc ça s'est bien passé le point
positif maintenant le point qui va être
un peu négatif
je vais les grands guillemets quand je
dis ça c'est effectivement avec ce petit
objet là vous ne pouvez pas être traqués
par des personnes tierces pour venir en
pause et un dans votre sac en loucedé
parce que ça va venir sonner pour que ça
ne fonctionnera pas donc ça c'est vrai
mais pour autant il existe un moyen pour
qu'une personne puisse vous suivre à
distance
je vous explique l'histoire c'est très
simple moi par exemple j'utilise ces
différents objets j'ai mon iphone j'ai
un ipad terre et j'ai un ipad pro
utilise les trois à la maison
oui absolument ce qui veut donc dire que
lorsque je pars me balader avec mes clés
ici avec mon portefeuille et bien je
pars dans la rue j'ai mon iphone avec
moi donc effectivement il n'y a pas de
problème tout fonctionne bien l'usagé
bombay pour autant chez moi on peut s'il
le souhaite venir utiliser mon ipad pour
savoir où est ce que je suis en temps
réel donc le suivi ne va pas se faire à
partir d'un compte qui n'est pas le
vôtre
il va se faire à partir de ce petit
objet là dans votre foyer
c'est à dire que si quelqu'un chez vous
quel qu'il soit au quelle qu'elle soit
peut importe des signes de savoir où est
ce que vous êtes au travers de sa grâce
à votre compte parce que oui moi ici
j'ai le même compte partout si mon
compte personnel
apple que je retrouvais également ici eh
bien il est complètement possible de
venir monsieur alors j'ai fait
l'expérience
j'ai posé mon ipad ici j'ai ouvert
l'application localiser et le parti
faire un tour et vous regardez c'est
sans appel il ya un suivi un vrai suivi
en temps réel
on voit où est ce que je suis on voit le
tour j'ai fait on voit où étaient mes
affaires qu'elle
j'ai j'avais emmené avec moi qui
comporte bien évidemment un airtag qui s
il n'ya airtag donc on peut me suivre
alors ça se passe au sein son propre
foyer il faut être sûr concept ton
propre foyer
il n'y a pas une personne qui cherche à
savoir où est ce que vous êtes la seule
façon ici de s'en prémunir
eh bien je dirais c'est devenir
déconnecté votre compte sur votre ipad
par exemple changer votre mot de passe
pour qu'on ne puisse pas venir vous
suivre et savoir où est ce que vous êtes
à votre insu mais c'est sensiblement la
même chose que de venir traquer un
iphone et dire d'un k-way mon iphone oui
mon ipad en temps réel sur le partage de
localisation donc voilà c'est là une
chose c'est une petite aparté
ça n'a rien à voir par rapport à
effectivement à ce que vous dit a peur
les ans quelqu un tiers quelqu'un qui
peut être un collègue de travail ou je
ne sais qui cherchent à vous suivre en
en plaçant dans votre sac non parce
qu'il faut qu'ils soient liés à votre
compte mais dès lors que vous avez le
même compte est bien là par contre on
peut vous suivre
donc ça c'est un petit truc il faut le
savoir je ne décide pas du tout ces
usages je tiens vraiment à le dire pour
qu'on le sache et que justement on
prenne les devants pour ne pas être
suivi imaginez par exemple que vous ayez
un ipad que vous passiez à votre enfant
et que les parents maîtres en airtag
dans le sac des enfants et bien grâce au
même conquis vont pouvoir les suivre à
distance soit depuis un ipad ou ipod
iphone c'est la même chose au sein d'un
couteau enfin voilà donc tout ça au sein
d'un foyer avec un même compte
il faut le savoir pour pouvoir
effectivement d'un prendre les devants
aucun à les dernières astuces un peu
plus légère je vais vous montrer comment
changer votre pile parce
qu'effectivement avoir ce bel appareil
c'est bien mais l'intérêt justement ce
qu'a fait apple qui est très juste ici
c'est de se dire qu'on peut venir
changer les pieds ici alors regardez ça
c'est votre airtag je pense que jusque
là tout va bien
volpi les lames et arrière ce que vous
faites ce que vous appuyez là et vous
faites glisser vos doigts sur le côté ça
vous permet de le libérer
vous avez votre pile vous le voyez là
c'est une petite pile tout simple vous
pouvez venir inchangé vous très
facilement c'est une cr 2032
c'est une 3 volts voilà las une petite
pile à panasonic qui nous ont bien
d'origine on vous l'a repositionné
dedans et vous avez fini vous mettez
bien en face là et là hop vous venez
tourner ensuite pour ça vienne bien
bloqué sa viennent bien le repositionner
attention attention surtout attention à
ne pas forcer à ne pas y aller avec un
tournevis pour faire levier ce que vous
avez des petits bourgs en plastique là
regardez là sur le côté là c'est ici en
fait que ça d'un script et ça se pose là
il vous le tournez sas met dedans
ce qui fait que si vous y allez avec un
tournevis
bourriner vous allez tout arraché tout
casser ça va plus fonctionner voilà donc
pour ces quelques astuces sur les aires
taglang l'air tag on en reparle dans
quelques jours pour regarder un peu les
usages sont gardés comment les retrouver
est-ce que c'est facile oui non si vous
voulez perdre et à l'autre bout d'une
ville est ce que vous allez pourtant
réussir à les récupérer comment est ce
que tout ça marche la fin dans quelques
jours d'ici là je vous invite à venir
vous abonner cliquez sur le petit bouton
rouge qu'elle a il est juste là si les
rouches si vous n'êtes pas abonné vous
actionnez la cloche comme ça vous serez
notifié qu'une prochaine vidéo arrivera
avec ça c'est très bien d'ici là
posez-moi toutes vos questions sur les
retards et je les regarderai pour y
répondre dans la prochaine vidéo
allez-y vous marquez tout ça on va t on
se retrouve très vite pour parler dr
tanguay pas d'autre chose à bientôt
ciao et n'oubliez pas live twitch tous
les jours de la semaine tous les matins
c'est la bonne nouvelle les 10 ou 15 15